hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter eight and some of Canterbury's
on freedom of choice has the interesting
title even God is not able to remove
uprightness of will and in that chapter
he's setting out an argument why it is
that God cannot remove or take away
uprightness that is rectitude o of will
rectitude oh Volvo Anton test which is
the purpose for which an Psalm says we
and other rational beings have freedom
of choice so when we do in fact
possessed rightness of will or
uprightness of will or however else you
want to talk about it rectitude these
are all good translations of that same
Latin term God himself can't take it
away which means that nothing else could
possibly take it away from a person and
in fact Anselm says we can lose it but
we lose it in every case by our own
choice to abandon it in favor of
something else now Anselm contrast this
to things that God in fact can do like
God can take a being that was created
and reduce it down to
thing but God can't remove rightness or
rectitude from a human will that
actually possesses it and that chooses
to keep it so what this means is that
God could take a human being and
completely efface them from all being
from the universe you know even God
forgets that person but God couldn't you
know provided that person remains there
go in and tweak them in such a way as to
take that out presumably God could you
know carry out the you know what we
might call ontological or metaphysical
surgery on other things God could take
away our ability to hear for example but
God can't take away this ability so it's
it's kind of an interesting assertion
and how does Anselm actually you know
support this well he says that up
rightness or rectitude of will means
that we will what God wills that we
ought to will he says this here in terms
of justice he says no will is just
except one which wills what God wills
that it will and there's a lot of wills
in there so let's let's break this down
you've got God over here and you've got
the human being over here the human
being over here could will a variety of
different things some of them would be
bad some of them would be good God wills
that is desires or wants or chooses you
know that the human being should will
this thing let's call it a and not B now
it's up to that human being whether they
do in fact will a or B and by willing a
they conform their will to the divine
will but God is not going to make that
person will it's not willing in that
sense the human being is not say an
extension of God the way my fingers are
extensions of myself
we're not instruments of God we're not
you know anything that God can send
we determine in that way we have freedom
of choice we have also the freedom in
another sense the power the ability to
choose between alternatives so the human
being does have a choice about how they
align their will how they worry in their
will so that might help us better to
understand what are you staying here
know will is just except one which wills
as the human being what God wills that
the human being wills so he says
therefore to keep uprightness of will
for the sake of uprightness itself is
for everybody keeping it to will what
God wills him to will so you know you
might Anselm doesn't go into this here
but you might you know think about other
instructions that have been provided you
know you want to know what is it that
God wants me to do well maybe you read
you know some of the scriptures and it
says well you shouldn't you know be
angry with your brother you should
reconcile before you go and engage in
any sort of service AHA that do willing
that would be willing what God wills me
to will
so that would be maintaining rightness
of will for its own sake now that
established what if God was to separate
the uprightness of the will from
somebody's will what if he was going to
carry out what I was facetiously
referring to as ontological or
metaphysical surgery he's gonna go into
your very soul and/or your will the
Faculty of will and say I see the
rightness part here let me cut that out
and pull that out let's see how the
person performs now well in some says
that wouldn't work why God would have to
do so in one way or another either God
would do so unwillingly or God would do
so willingly now can God do anything
unwillingly no because there's nothing
at least an answer
ontology powerful enough to force God to
do anything against God's will
there's nothing that can stand against
it or in front of it let alone to coerce
or compel it and you know you might say
well maybe God could do something and
he's not you know totally present at the
moment thinking about what he what he's
doing and so he makes a mistake does
that work with the the traditional
conception of God no not really so
that's not an option
God can't unwillingly remove rectitude
or rightness of will from a person's
will so he has to do it willingly
well that raises some problems that some
logical problems because this would
create a contradiction how so
so Ansem goes on and he says that there
we go if he were to remove this
uprightness from someone with someone's
Willy would will what he did and then he
says from whomever's will he God would
will to separate this unrighteousness
right uprightness surely God would not
will this person to keep uprightness of
will for the sake of uprightness itself
but we've already posited as true that
to keep uprightness of will in this
manner is for everyone keeping it to
will what God wants or wills him to will
and he says so if God were to remove
this uprightness from someone he would
not will him - will what He wills him -
will that's a little bit more
complicated again so let let's break it
down so God would not will that person
to keep uprightness of will for its own
sake if he were to remove it from the
person's will but keeping uprightness of
will for its own sake is for that person
- will what God wills that person - will
there's three different wills in there
so you want to you know keep that kind
of clear in your head let's say that one
more time keeping uprightness of will is
- will for
person to will what God wills that
person to will so God is both willing
that person to keep or maintain
uprightness of will for its own sake and
not willing for that person to keep
uprightness of will for its own sake
in fact willing against that which means
that God would have two different things
to different wills bearing upon the same
thing God would be wanting something to
be the case and not the case at the same
time God would be willing a
contradiction right and so this means
that that you know as ants I'll put it
God would not will what God wills we
have a contradiction there that doesn't
work and so therefore God cannot take
away rectitude of will from the the will
of somebody who wants to keep it it
wouldn't make sense and you might say
well that seems like a unfair
restriction on God's you know infinite
power no this is actually a condition
you know for our God's infinite power
you know sort of you should say residing
in or unfolding from that very power
itself now Anselm concludes this chapter
by saying that nothing is more
impossible than for God to remove
uprightness of will nevertheless we when
we're speaking in precisely we do
sometimes say that he does this when he
does not cause this uprightness not to
be deserted so when God doesn't maintain
somebody else give them the strength
that they need to not make a bad
decision and abandon uprightness of will
but really what's happening in that case
is God is simply you know not
interfering in the situation and he's
allowing the person to make their own
choice
so God can't do this thing and that
shows us just how powerful according to
an Psalm the capacity to maintain
uprightness of will for its own sake
actually is
for us human beings
you